yes i'm totally fine
i'm extremely happy i have a beautiful
home beautiful children
brittany who recently made a rare public
appearance to shop in malibu
tried to reassure her worried fans i'm
taking a break right now because
i'm enjoying myself but her posts
including this fashion video come amidst
a startling development in her
conservatorship case
her once close parents are facing off
against each other
we're very close and we heck we're
raised in the family together and we're
we're best friends e.t has obtained
court documents filed by lynn spears
brittany's mom is objecting to a request
by her ex-husband jamie for attorney's
fees totaling more than 890 thousand
dollars
keep in mind that money is paid out of
brittany's estate
lynn calls the request substantively
improper
some of that money 224 000 was allegedly
used for press relations
if she wants to end her conservatorship
she can file a petition to end it
including tv interviews by jamie's
attorney to quote
combat media coverage that cast mr
spears in a negative light
jamie loves his daughter the issue is
expected to be discussed at brittany's
next conservatorship hearing
a week from today
you